so
um just explain a little bit who i am i
am
um the lecturer in the sociology of new
media and digital technology at
cambridge
where i also co-direct the center of
governance and human rights as you can
imagine my research is in the
intersection of technology
and human rights and i lead an academic
startup which is called the whistle
where we build technologies for human
rights accountability working very
closely with
ngo partners so um today
there are two parts to my mini course
the first is on
the challenge to facts as in
facts as we have known them not facts
themselves so facts arising from new
technologies
being brought into the human rights
fact-finding space
um so we're going to start first with an
understanding
of you know what these new technologies
are doing
how we can verify the data they produce
because it's very different from how
human rights fact-finding used to happen
before
and also some tech projects in
development to support these new
practices and then after that we have a
session which is on the future
um and that is i don't want to sound
bleak but i start off with a bunch of
warnings
right um uh a warning really around
what we might have gotten ourselves into
without meaning to
in our excitement about these new
technologies and how their adoption
may be threatening the very values at
the core of human rights fact-finding
so on to our first part challenges like
i said this is not
um challenges to facts per se i don't
actually believe we're living in a
post-truth era
it's a challenge to where facts come
from
um what they look like and the tools
not the principles but the tools of how
they're assessed how what we use to
assess them right
so let's start back slightly before the
kind of
mega rise the digital age to maybe a
decade ago
right thinking about human rights
fact-finding
and um the gold standard of how human
rights fact-finding was done
this was with the interview
and for many decades it's been the
interview and it still really is the
interview the face-to-face interview
the fact-finders are face-to-face with
people they're taking notes
they can talk to different people and
corroborate their stories
they are there in the context of that
place they can look around them
use information around them to build the
story
that's all very important for the
verification part right
they can look at the witness and they
can read the witness
as a person you know look for cues and
tells
the way that any of us do when we're
interacting with someone else in
conversation to judge whether or not
they're telling the truth
but just as important as this
verification process
is the solidarity that's going on
in this moment okay that is just as
important to human rights witnessing
human rights facts finding
solidarity so that is a feeling of
mutual support
a feeling of shared goals right a
feeling of shared feelings
about what's going on and solidarity is
underpinned by a demonstration of trust
right you have to have trust first to
build solidarity
verification and solidarity they go hand
in hand
fact finders get more information about
a human rights violation the more trust
they can build
and the sometimes kind of hard-nosed
nature of verification the kind of
fact-building
is tempered and made worthwhile by the
solidarity built between civilian
witnesses
and professional fact finders not to
mention the fact that getting any kind
of justice for human rights is a very
long road
so you know it is something to sustain
you as you're trying to make social
change
so this has been the gold standard and
then
this is called really the sort of second
generation of fact-finding
um the first generation was much more
about documentary analysis and speaking
to experts
the second one was about field visits
and these interviews
and then the third generation came along
a few years ago sorry i forgot to give
you
the quote from human rights watch about
uh their interviewing process which
really goes to show
sort of what uh it is that's involved in
terms of you know taking care
of your witness and building that
solidarity it basically is saying
that being very careful with their
witnesses they're
trained to approach interview
interviewees at the appropriate time
and they're trained to communicate with
sensitivity in a setting that is secure
and private the interviewee will be
informed of the purpose and the scope of
the interview
consent will be given and the interview
will be ensured of their anonymity
there's also something here that says
that if the interviewer feels that the
interviewee
that the witness is not emotionally
ready to do this they'll stop
right there's a lot of care and
solidarity built into this practice
so like i said this is the second
generation now we're on to the third
generation
and it's radically different so here you
have just some examples of what's going
on
of course you have the mobile phone
right that dramatically changed the kind
the amount and the sources of human
rights information in the world
because suddenly anyone who had a phone
and witnessed something if they remember
it in time could take out their phone
and document it
and then they could post it publicly on
social media they could send it
privately on whatsapp
they could reach out to the world with
it that's a huge change
you have satellites so satellite images
are becoming
much more prevalent and much cheaper
than ever before
so if there's a place you can't get to
to do a human rights investigation
you can still if the conditions are
right if the kind of thing you're trying
to investigate is the right kind of
thing
use a satellite to figure out what's
going on so for example if you're
looking for the
destruction of villages in a place where
there's not constant cloud cover be
harder
probably here but in a place where
there's sunshine and satellites can take
pictures
you can do things like before and afters
and look for this
then we have uh the kind of looming
future
that i think people in this space are
both terrified about and kind of
excited about because it's the new
challenge
which is um deep fakes and holograms
right so deep fakes you probably know
what they are you've certainly heard of
them i'm sure because they're all over
the news
but it's basically where audio and video
can be manipulated to make people look
like they're saying things that they
weren't saying or doing things they
weren't doing
so this was quite famous clip of obama
where he's saying uh a swear word
a nasty word about his successor
something that you know president obama
would never have done but it was you
know it went out there
and in a way it demonstrated to us what
a deep fake could do because it was
incredibly convincing
um then we have holograms right and
i hadn't even thought about this and
then a fact finder told me well you know
i don't know what we're going to do when
these become mainstream because
basically the idea with a hologram
is that you can take whatever the
hologram is
this is actually um the indonesian
president's hologram
so he was campaigning for reelection
this spring
and he couldn't get to every last little
town that he wanted to get to so he sent
his hologram instead
and apparently ironically the hologram
was talking about fake news
but anyway the indonesian president yeah
um so uh but the idea with these
holograms
is that um right now it's still possible
to know if an image has been doctored
there's things you can do to sort of
figure that out but with the hologram
the doctrine is in reality
right so you project a hologram of a
person into a location
and then you shoot a video of it and the
video has not been doctored right
so as long as a hologram is realistic
enough it's supposed to be a convincing
fake now i don't think this is happening
at all yet but
people think it's on the frontier so
these you can see are just proliferating
and they're radically different from
that face-to-face
intimate relationship building interview
what i'm going to do now
is just give you a few examples of
little vignettes of cases
just so you can see what kinds of
challenges these new types of
technologies turf up
so the first example is from 2018
it was yet another attack in this
yearning conflict
this time in duma eastern ghouta where
bombing has left the marketplace
absolutely devastated and there's a team
of student investigators
some of whom were at cambridge with me
um who are trying to identify the
position of a local hospital
after they located a video on twitter
showing dozens of
really heavily injured individuals being
hospitalized
um so these students belong to the
digital digital verification core
which is a project where amnesty
international
globally is partnering with universities
to train the next generation of human
rights investigators
so these students are working with
amnesty to discover and verify
information
um to help amnesty researchers kind of
give give them extra capacity to find
evidence
um and so they found this video
and they're looking at it and they're
pretty sure they want to say it's a
documentation of the results of this
attack um it's been tweeted by a number
of different users
each time there's been texts underneath
saying that this is the victims of the
marketplace bombing
and the students are thinking to
themselves if they could if they could
absolutely say with certainty where this
hospital is
then they would be better able to assess
the scale of the attack through an
indication of the minimum number of
victims
and this information they can then give
to amnesty's investigators who are
trying to establish the facts of the
event
the problem is the video gives very
little away about where this hospital is
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas